On October 7th, Brazilian voters went to
the polls to choose a new president
and Congress — in one of the most
complicated and polarizing elections in
that country's history. Jair Bolsonaro
and Fernando Haddad have advanced to
the second round. Bolsonaro's strong
finish — falling just short of a
first round victory — stunned the country's
political class. His tough talk resonated
with many voters, who are fed up with
widespread political corruption and
staggering crime rates. Haddad is the
stand-in for former president Lula da Silva.
Although his big-government message
resonates with the country's poor,
the Workers' Party took a
beating in the first round.
Economic growth is sluggish. Corruption
scandals have fueled cynicism.
Murder rates six-times that of the United States
are a security crisis. And this campaign has
polarized public opinion. Bolsonaro
has the edge, but Haddad can appeal to
millions of voters who did not
participate in the first round.
Both will try to make the case before the
October 28th runoff that he's the man
who can put Brazil's house in order.
What does the future hold for Brazil?
Let us know in your comments
and let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.